[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي تستهلها في
ابرز العناوين
الامن الايراني
منتخب المغرب ينتزع نقطه ثمينه من وصيف
بطل العالم السابق منتخب كرواتيا في
مونديال كره القدم
خطه اوروبيه لفرض سقف على سعر النفط
الروسي وموسكو ترد بالتهديد بخفض
امداداتها من الغاز الى الاوروبي
ازمه تويتر تتفاقم والمنصه تخسر ثلث
المعلنين الكبار على مدار اسبوعين
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه نبدا النشره من
ايران في عقب خساره المنتخب الايراني
مباراته الافتتاحيه في مونديال كره القدم
بسته اهداف مقابل هدفين امام انجلترا
ساعات وسائل الاعلام الايرانيه الى القاء
اللون في الهزيمه على الاضطرابات التي
اجتاحت البلاد منذ مقتل محسنين في منتصف
سبتمبر الماضي هذا فيما لجات صحفا عده الى
اتهام من وصفتهم بالاعداء الاجانب وفي
طليعاتهم الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
واسرائيل باثاره الاحتجاجات لاخراج
المنتخب الوطني عن تركيز
هذا ما كشفت منظمه حقوق الانسان في ايران
ومقرها العاصمه النرويجيه اوسلو عن مقتل
416 شخصا من بينهم 51 طفلا واحدى و20
امراه على ايدي القوات الامنيه الايرانيه
منذ اندلاع الاحتجاجات في منتصفه سبتمبر
الماضي وفي الاسبوع الماضي وحده لقيا 72
شخصا حتفهم بينهم 56 في مناطق يقتلها
الاكراد في غرب ايران حيث تصاعدت حملات
القمع ضد الاحتجاجات خلال الايام الاخيره
ومع تصاعدي زخم الاحتجاجات دعم شطاء
للاضراب العام ردا على قمع قوات الامن
اتجاه المدن الكرديه غرب البلاد مجموعه
باسم الشباب الثوار في ايران دعت الى
اغلاق المحلات والاعمال التجاريه بينما
طلب مركز التعاون الاحزاب الكرديه في
ايران المنظمات السياسيه والنشطاء
المدنيين والشعب الايراني الى الانضمام
الى الاضراب لدعم الاحتجاجات ورفضه
للتعامل لقوات الامن مع الاقليه
اما في المدن الكرديه في ايران فتحولت
الشوارع الى ساحه حرب حيث تصاعدت
المواجهات بين المحتاجين وقوات الامن فيما
ارسلت السلطات الايرانيه قوات لفرض مزيد
من القمع في محاوله منها لوقف اتساع
التظاهرات
وقد افاده ان القوات الامن فرضت اجراءات
امنيه مشدده عندما داخل المدن الكرديه
ومنعت ايصال المساعدات الطبيه الاغاثيه
للجرح في المقابل هددت السلطات الايرانيه
من جديد عبر نائب قائد الحرس الثوري
الايراني بانها ستتعاملوا بحزم مع كل من
ارتكب جريمه او شارك في الاحتجاجات
معي ميني بروكسل لمزيد من المتابعه حول
هذا الموضوع من السيلاوي وهي باحثه في
الشان الايراني يس اتمنى اهلا وسهلا بك
الى نشره الخامسه بدايه هل بدات السلطات
الايرانيه وفق متابعتك تستشعر بشكل حقيقي
حجم الازمه الداخليه ام لا ما زالت تتعاطى
بالموقف السابق عدم وجود ازمه اصلا او ما
يعرف بالانجليزيه الدينايل
هم لديهم بعد من الانكار ودين
بعض من الخلط الاوراق يعني عندما نشاهد
النظام يذهب الى عائله
ويستغيث بهم ويطلب منهم مساعده اخمدوا
شارع الايراني وكانه ما هم ممكن حتى يكون
لديهم همم اي قوه على الشارع الثاني يبين
ماذا يعني هذا النظام اما بالنسبه للتصرف
اللي يتصرفونها في كردستان هي تصرف همم
بالفعل انها همم انها جريمه ضد الانسانيه
يعني هم فتحوا النار ودخلوا في كل قواهم
العسكريه في منطقه سكانها المدنيين ويحاول
ان يرسلوا الرساله واضحه لباقي مناطق
الايرانيه بانه في حاله استمروا في هذه
الاحتجاجات همم سيكون هذا مصيرهم يعني حتى
الان النظام يحاول قمع المناطق بالنسبه
لهم ممكن اسهل ااه قامها مثل كردستان
ومناطق الاقليات الاخرى في حال ما زال
يحافظ على بعض من الاستقرار والامان مثلا
في الجامعات او في مثلا كازيه مثل اصفه
شيراز وفي المقابل تقوم بايد للحديد في
كردستان همم هل ما زالت مقوله المؤامره
الخارجيه من امريكا وحلفائها رائجه همم
ولها مؤيدون في الاوصاف الشعبيه الايرانيه
ام لا حتى هذه الحجه
لم تعد صالحه او لم تعد بضاعه رائجه
يعني يقبلها شعب الايراني وهناك نظريه
مؤامره
ها الحكومه يعني الحكومه الايرانيه تقول
ان الغرب تتامل
تتامر على على النظام الايراني في القطف
الايراني الغربي
وتامر شعب الايراني واثبت هذا النظام لا
ننسى انه خميني كان في منفاه في فرنسا
في بدايه الثوره قال اتصرح انه صوره خميني
في القمر صاروا يشوفون صوره خميني بالقمر
تعرف انه شكل القمر في الها شغل مبهم
فممكن واحد يتخيل فتخيل وخميني صورته
بمعجزه دخل في القمر يعني وايضا جواد ظريف
وكثير من شاكرته كانه في جامعات في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولايه المتحده
الامريكيه لم تتحرك ساكن عندما هجموا على
السفاره الامريكيه ان هناك نظريه مؤامره
شعب الايراني اذا المؤمن فيها انه بالفعل
انه دول الغربي تغيير النظام ممكن النظام
يقول كل هذه المؤامرات ولكن لما نرى تصرف
الانظمه الغربيه جيران اتجاه ايران انا
ارى نظريه مؤامره يؤمن فيها شعب الايراني
مقابل كان الغالب يتوقع امام هذا الضغط
همم والمواقف المنتقده والممدده انت تراجع
ايران او السلطات في ايران خطوه او خطوتين
الى الوراء لكن لدي شاهدناه لا العكس
طهران رفعت قفازه التحدي بوجه الاوروبيين
واعلنت بالامس البادئ بالتفصيل
بنسبه 60% لليورانيوم وهي العتبه النوويه
يعني مش فارقه معه
بالفايه النظام الايراني والمولالي لا لا
يهمهم تن- تنديدات الغربيه الا اذا كانت
هناك بالفعل همم يكون هناك تهديد جدا يعني
عندما وقع على اتفاق النووي كان هناك
ايران كانت على وشك ان تدخل البند السابع
للمجلس الامن يعني لولا هذا بتقول لولا
العقوبات اللي كانت بالفعل يعني كسر
الظاهره الاقتصاد الايراني لم كانت توافق
على الاتفاق النووي ولكن من بعد يعني بعد
اتفاق النووي فلا تدوا الغربيه ال- اا كل
الزمان الامور لذلك النظام الايراني اذا
انت ماذا يعني كل هذه التمديدات حتى لو لم
يكونوا يندد وكانت النظام تقوم في هذا
القمع الوحشي لا ننسى في مره اخرى 400 رقم
كبير ولكن في ازمه المحروقات نحن فقدنا
1,500 واحد خلال اسبوعين عندما قطعوا
الانترنت قمعوا الشعر يعني تمديدات ما
معناها ايران رافعات بالفعل العكس من ذلك
ممكن ايران متراجعه قليلا همم مقارنه
انطباق بتصرفاتها في احتجاجات السابقه من
بروكسل الممثل الاول الباحثه في الشان
الايراني شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
تتطور والاحتجاجات في انحاء ايران بوتيره
متسارعه لكن الانظار الان تتجه نحو
الملتقى الغربيه محافظه كردستان
قوات النظام حملاته الامنيه العنيفه فيها
منظمه هنغاو لحقوق الانسان مقرها كردستان
العراق اشارت الى ان اكثر من ثمانين
متظاهرا قتلوا وتوكل 4 في المناطق ذات
الاغلبيه الكرديه وحدها
تحدثت بمنظمه حقوق الانسان في ايران التي
تتخذ من اوزلو مقر لها في اخر حصيله
اصدرتها عن مصرع 72 شخصا الاسبوع الماضي
وحده بينهم 56 في مناطق يقتلها الاكراد
بالغرب وثقت لجنه متابعه معتقلين في ايران
شل النظام الايراني حمله اعتقالات واسعه
في مدن مهابات
الكرديه ومدينه ايران شهر في بلوشستان
ووسط تقارير تفيد بقمع وانتهاكات جسيمه
يقوم بها النظام الايراني ضد المعتقلين في
سجونه والثقافه مفوضيه حقوق الانسان
اعتقال الالاف الانضمامهم الى الاحتجاجات
السلميه ندعو ايران لاطلاق سراح المعتقلين
واسقاط التهامي الموجهه اليهم ونطالبها
بتعليق فوري لعقوبه الاعدام
حماله القمع الايرانيه اتخذت استراتيجيه
شاذه في محاوله لكبح المتظاهرين من
التعذيب والاعدام وحتى الاغتصاب
فقد كشفت شبكه سي ان الامريكيه وفقا لشهود
في التقرير
قوه الامن داخل السجون الى تصوير بعض
مشاهد العنف الجنسي لاستخدامها اداه
لابتزاز المتظاهرين
الا ان النظام الايراني
المتظاهرين عن الاستمرار احتجاجاتهم
واستدعوات للاضراب العام اطلقها نشطاء
ايرانيون البدايه من الغد تمديدا بقمع قوه
الامن المحتجين في المدن الكرديه
معي من منطقه الركن السعوديه في الدوحه
العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن
تحياتي لك اولا كيف الاجواء من عندك وهل
كانت الجماهير العربيه راضيه على اداء
منتخب اسود الاطلس اليوم ضد كرواتيا
نعم الطالب
جماهير الدول العربيه للمنتخب المغربي
اليوم
المنتخب السعودي خطف الانظار يوم الامس في
نتيجه تاريخيه على المنتخب الارجنتيني الا
ان المنتخب المغربي قبل بدايه هذه البطوله
كان مرشح بان يؤدي
مباريات جيده نظرا لترسانه النجوم التي
لدى المنتخب المغربي بالنظر الى الانديه
التي يلعبون
الفئه الاولى في اوروبا لذلك كان المنتخب
المغربي اليوم ضد منتخب كرواتيا وصيه في
العالم وهمم يملك وهو منتخب يملك المع
النجوم حول العالم كان المنتخب المغربي
نبدا له همم وانتهت المباراه بالتعادل
بالرغم من ان المنتخب المغربي يقع في
مجموعه صعب بين كرواتيا وبلجيكا منتخبان
قويان مرشحان ان يصل الى
ادوار متقدمه في بطوله كاس العالم الى ان
المنتخب المغربي الكثير يعول علي الامال
بالنظر الى الترسانه النجوم لديه خلافا
لذلك كان هناك همم دعني احدثك عن حصيله
الجوله لدى المنتخبات العربيه
تعادلان وخساره وانتصار تاريخي همم ربما
بعد يتحدث عن جوله ايجابيه لك
للمنتخبات العربيه بشكل عام وانا المنتخب
القطري خسر مباراه الافتتاح الا ان
التعادلات بالنسبه للمغرب وتونس همم لم
يكن الافضل ولكن ليس هو الاسود ومتبقي
مبارتان ممكن التعويض بهما والفوز به همم
نتيجه المباريات القادمه
في الحقيقه طالب الامنيات لدى الجماهير
العربيه والتوقعات وسقف الطموح يرتفع بشكل
كبير جدا بعد فوز المنتخب السعودي يوم
الامس هذا الفوز سكن لحظه فارقه في هذه
البطوله وفي تاريخ هذه البطوله بشكل عام
لكن في هذه البطوله تحديدا شكل لحظه فارغ
لدى كل المشجعين المنتخبات العربيه شهدنا
يوم الامس في هذه الساعه في الركن السعودي
المغربي والتونسي والقطري والسعودي
والفلسطيني والعراق وكافه
الدول العربيه المواطنين الدول العربيه
يحتفلون جنبا الى جنبي بمناسبه الانتصار
التاريخ
موجود في الركن السعودي وتتابع الامور
يعني عن كثب اكثر منه هنا كيف هي
استعدادات المنتخب السعودي للمباراه
للمباراه التاليه
الاستعدادات الطالب بدات منذ انتهاء
مباراه يوم الامس كان هناك حديث كبير عن
الاصابات التي تعرض لها نجوم المنتخب يوم
الامس تتحدث عن سلمان الفرج واصابه لا
يستطيع من خلالها المشاركه بمباريات
القادمه
ادخلته الى المستشفى لاجراء عمليه مباشره
فبالتالي هنالك غيابان مؤثرات على المنتخب
السعودي في المباراه القادمه لنا الاعمال
الكبيره على نجوم المنتخب السعودي على
حاليا الذين اثبتوا يوم الامس بانهم
قادرون على تجاوز كافه التحديات التيما
وانهم تجاوزهم في منتخب الارجنتيني
المنتخب السعودي عاد الى مؤسسه يوم الامس
وبدا في الاستعداد للمباراه القادمه ويا
امام هولندا متبقي عليها تقريبا ثلاثه
ايام ستكون يوم السبت فبالتالي هم دخلوا
في الاعداد النهائي المباراه الثانيه
الدوحه من منطقه الركن السعودي في الدوحه
منفرد العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي شكرا
جزيلا لك عبد المحسن على كل هذه المتابعه
[موسيقى]
النشاط الخامس مستمره في ايضا
البرلمان الاوروبي يصوت بالموافقه على
تصنيف روسيا دوله راعيه للارهاب
الاوكرانيون
بالاضافه الى سته جارحه اخرين جرى القصف
الروسيه اليوم على العاصمه
العربيه
في المدينه وجاء ذلك بعد وقوع انفجارات
مشابهه في مناطق عده في شرق وجنوب البلاد
حيث تستهدف القوات الروسيه بشكل متزايد
البنيه التحتيه الحيويه لاوكرانيا من جهه
اخرى اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن
اسقاطه خمس مسيرات فوق البحر الاسود
ومنطقه القرد
هذا وقال عمد تركيا فيتالي كليتشكو ان
شتاء قاطما وقارصا ينتظر سكان العاصمه
الاوكرانيه البالغ عددهم ثلاثه ملايين
نسمه بسبب الاضرار التي لحقت بالبنيه
التحتيه للطاقه في البلاد جراء القصف
الروسي
واضاف كليتو لصحيفه بلد الالمانيه ان هذا
الشتاء سيكون الاسوء منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه مطالبا المانيا بارسال مولدات
كهربائيه وملابس واقيه وسيله عن انسانيه
بشكل سريع بالاضافه الى اسلحه الدفاعيه
وبحسب السلطات الاوكرانيه قد يواجهوا
الملايين بمن فيهم سكان انقطاعات في
الكهرباء حتى نهايه شهر مارس على الاقل
قبل ذلك بحث مدير عام الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه رفع ال جروس مع وفد الروسي
بمدينه اسطنبول التركيه بحث ضروره انشائي
منطقه للامن والامان النووي حول محطه
الطاقه النوويه في زباروجيا وبحسب الوكاله
عق- عقد الاجتماع لبحث الجوانب التشغيليه
المرتبطه بالامان في المحطه النوويه
لتفادي وقوع كارثه نوويه ياتي ذلك بعد
التعرض المحطه لقصف خلال عطله نهايه
الاسبوع حيث يتبادلت موسكو وكتابه
لاتهامات بالمسؤوليه عن قصف المحطه
من جانبي اكد المستشار الالماني الاوبشنز
ان امن الطاقه بالنسبه لبلاده اصبح مضمونا
وقال في تصريحات له ان المانيا تتجه بقوه
نحو تغيير السياسات التي ادت الى الاعتماد
من جانب واحد على روسيا
هذا وظلت ازمه الطاقه احد ابرز التحديات
التي تواجه اوروبا اثار الحرب في اوكرانيا
فبالتزامن مع تحركات اوروبيه لتحديد سعر
النفط حدد موسكو بيخفض امدادات الغاز
المتجهه الى غرب اوروبا
التي تمر عبر اوكرانيا ابتداءا من الاسبوع
المقبل
وقت ذلك فيما تستعد الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها للاتفاق على تحديد السقف لسعر
النفط الروسي بحد اقصى يصل الى 70 دولارا
للبرميل فيما اقترحت المفوضيه الاوروبيه
فرض قيود طارق على اسعار الغاز الطبيعي
لمنع مزيد من الضرر الذي قد يلحق
بالاقتصاد الاوروبي
ومع ذلك فان تمريره قرار تحديد سقف اسعار
الغاز الروسي ما يزال محل خلاف بين الدول
الاوروبيه نفسها حيث ذكرت صحيفه
رومانسيه
تسود بين دول الاتحاد الاوروبي بسبب نيه
الاتحاد فرض السقف لسعر الغاز الروسي
ووفقا للصحيفه فان ممثلين الدول المؤيده
للقيود الدروسيا يعتبرون الخطه المعلنه
غير ناجحه وان فرض سقف لسعر الغاز لان
ينهي مشاكل الوقود في اوروبا بل سيعود
بنتائج عكسيه وخيمه على السوق
لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا الموضوع معي من
باريس الباحثه السياسيه مايا خضراء ماي
اهلا وسهلا بك الى نشاط الخامسه هل فعلا
الدول الغربيه تحديدا الاوروبيون مايا
متفقون الان على تحديث سقف لسعر النفط
الروسي ام لا هذه مجرد تمنيات عند وقت
اتخاذ القرار لا سترجع الخلافات وستتراجع
بعض الدول الاوروبيه عن الموافقات تحديدا
المانيا همم هنغاريا وغيرها من الدول
الاوروبيه
نعم في هذا الاطار كان هناك البارحه
اجتماعا للمفوضيه الاوروبيه تم اقتراح
نوع من القانون او ليس قانون ولكن سموها
بالميكانيكوريكسيون
اليه تصحيح السوق التجاري للغاز في
الاتحاد الاوروبي ولكن هذه الاليه
المقترحه لاقت نوعا مع اعتراضا المانيا من
قبل دوله هولندا لماذا لان المنصه التي
يتم عبرها توزيع الغاز في اوروبا
هي متواجده في دوله هولندا وهي مسؤوله عن
توزيعه منين بالميه من الغاز المستورد من
روسيا على الاصوات الاوروبيه الذي تم
اقتراحه همم البارحه في المفوضيه
الاوروبيه هو ليس وضع سقف ليه السعر الغاز
لانه هناك سعرا عالميا ولكن وضع نوعا
ضوابط في حال مكان هناك شرطان متوفرا
متوفرا وهما اولا ان لا يتخطى سعر
الميجاوات 275 يورو وان لا يكون هناك
فارقا يتخطط 150 يورو ما بين سعر الغاز
الذي يباع في اوروبا وسعر الغاز العالمي
هناك شرطان اذا لهذا السقف وذلك وهذا ما
حدث في شهر ابسطس من هذه السنه في الصيف
حيث تخطي سعر الهمم الميجاوات في الساعه
300 يورو وكان هناك همم اليه من قبل
الاتحاد الاوروبي لتخفيض نوعا ما هذا
السعر ولكن الاتحاد الاوروبي لا يريد ان
يضع سقفا كما يقال لي سعر الغاز كلا هو
يريد الحد من بعض التجاوزات التي تقام من
قبل بعض من الشركات الاوروبيه التي تستفيد
من الازمه
زياده
لانه في اجتماع القادم اتفق الاوروبيون
على هذه المتصفينه بالض- بالضوابط علما
انروس تعتبر ذلك تصطيف بسعر نفطها طيب
ولكن هل يعرف الاوروبيون ماذا ينتظرهم من
قبل موسكو يعني موسكو مازال لديها الكثير
من الاوراق لتلعبها ولا يجب الاستهانه هل
يعني همم هل يعرفون ماذا ينتظرهم الرد
الروسي لانه هددت موسكو اليوم بشكل واضح
بالفعل
هناك همم الذي يعرفه الاوروبيون وهو ما
يتجلى في الموقف الالماني وموقف دوله
هولندا هاتين الدولتين هاتين اعترضتا على
وضع سقف لي او ضوابط لسعر النفط هو فعلا
لان روسيا تهدد به تخفيض
صادراتها من الغاز والنفط الى اوروبا بعد
ما تم استهداف نوت 3 هناك قنوات اخرى
وانابيب اخرى تمر في اوروبا الشرقيه وتمر
حتى في همم اوكرانيا ايضا وهذا التهديد
الروسي بالفعل يتم اخذه على محمل الجد من
الدول الاوروبيه ولذلك هناك شرخ ما بين
هذه الدول هناك اليونان بولندا همم
ايطاليا وحتى بلجيكا هي دول توافق على وضع
هذا السقف ولكن دول كبر صناعيه كافا فرنسا
كالمانيا
نوعا ما على كل هذه الضوابط وبالفعل
بالنسبه له يجب اخذ على محمل الجد هذا
التهديد الروسي همم ابليس صادرات الغاز
لان هذه السياسه بدات في اوكرانيا
فلاديمير بوتين تواعد الشعب الاوكراني دي
نوعا ما بان يقضي شتاءا قارسا وان يقضي
ايضا شتاء في الظلام وهذا ما يمكن ان يحدث
في الكثير من العواصم الاوروبيه انا اليوم
انه هناك
القدر شكرا جزيلا لك من باريس الباحثه
السياسيه ما يخبره
قرر البرلمان الاوروبي تصنيف الروسيا دوله
الرعايه للارهاب في قرار غير ملزم لكنه
ذات رمزيه كبيره وجاء في القرار ان
الضربات العسكريه التي تنفذها موسكو على
اهداف المدنيه مثل البنيه التحتيه للطاقه
والمستشفيات ومدارس وملاجئ في اوكرانيا
تنتهي القانون الدولي وايد القرار مئه و91
صوتا مقابله معارضه 58 صوتا وامتناع 44
اخرين
هذا ورحب الرئيس الاوكرانيس
روسيا في جميع المحافظ الدوري
البيت الابيض في تفجير اين وقع صباح اليوم
في القدس واسفراء عن مقتل شخص واصابه
اخرين افاده مراسل العربيه بوجود اسم فارس
بعد الهجومين الذين استهدفه محطتين حافلات
عند مدخل المدينه واضاف ان الشرطه
الاسرائيليه اعتقل ثلاثه اشخاص
وقال التقارير اسرائيليه ان من بين
المصابين ثلاثه اشخاص في حاله خطره وذكرت
اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي ان الانفجار الاول
وقع قرب محطه حافلات بمدخل القدس وادى الى
اصابه 13 شخصا بينما وقع الانفجار الثاني
في مفرق حي رموات الاستيطاني وادى لاصابه
شخصين
هذا ورفعت اسرائيل درجه اهوب خشيه من
عمليات تفجيريه او مسلحه جديده وكان رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي قد اجرى تقييما امنيا
مع وزير الدفاع والامن الداخلي في اعقاب
تفجير القدس التفاصيل مع الزميل زياد حلب
نحن هنا في موقع الانفجار للعمليه الاولى
التفجيريه التي حدثت على مدخل مدينه القدس
بالنسبه لاسرائيل فانه بالاضافه الى
الحصيله مقتل عدد من الاسرائيليين واصابه
عدد اخر في هذه العمليه وفي العمليه تفجير
ثانيه ليست بعيده عن هذا المكان ايضا
اسرائيل تضرب اخماسا باسداس في محاوله
فهمم ما هي هذه العمليه هل هي انتقال من
العمليات الفرديه التي كانت تشهدها
اسرائيل على جانبي الخط الاخضر الى عمليات
اكثر تنظيما عمليا من قبل همم المنظمات
الفلسطينيه داخل الخط الاخضر هذه العمليات
التفجيريه غير مسبوقه عمليا
عام 2016 وميزت اساسا الانتفاضه الثانيه
لهذا هناك تخوف اسرائيلي جدي من امكان ان
تعود الى عمليات التفجيريه الى وسط المدن
الاسرائيليه وهذه العمليه بدات ايضا كانها
رساله لحكومه انتهت ولايتها ولحكومه يمنيه
متطرفه لم تتشكل بعد
زياد حلبي العربيه القدس الغربيه
نشاط الخامس المستمره في ايضا
تركيا
في شمال سوريا والعراق واردوغان يبرر
العمليات بحمايه امنياء
اهلا بكم جديد برا رئيس تركيا رجب طيب
اردوغان العمليات العسكريه في شمال سوريا
والعراق بان تركيا لديها الحق في التعامل
مع المشاكل الامني وحدد اردوغان ومزيد من
الهجمات الجويه التي تم تنفيذها ليست سوى
البدايه وان العمليات البريه ستبدا في
الوقت المناسب على حديث تعبيره هذا وشدد
اردوغان على ان تركيا مستمره في الالتزام
بالاتفاقات المتعلقه بالحدود مع سوريا
وردا على تهديدات التركيه كد قائد القوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه الاستعداد للتصدي لغزو
بري تركي وشيك في شمال شرق سوريا مبديا
فيقته بالوصول لمستوى يمكن هذه القوات من
احباط اي هجوم جديد حسب تعبير
وحذر القيادي في قصد من اتساع نطاق الحرب
لتشمل جميع المناطق في حاله الهجوم التركي
مشددا على ان المعركه ستكون كبيره ولن
يتيحوا للاتراك فرصه السيطره على المزيد
من مناطقي
من جانبها دعت روسيا تركيا الى الامتناع
عن شنه هجوم بري في سوريا وقال المبعوث
الروسي الى سوريا ان مثل هذه الاعمال يمكن
ان تؤدي الى تصعيد العنف ويجب عدم السماح
بذلك
الى اسطنبول انضم اليه من هناك الدكتور
بكير اتجان مدير معهد اسطنبول للفكر
الدكتور بكير اهلا وسهلا بك حتى الساعه
الامور غامضه وحماله اهلا حتى الساعه
الامور غامضه الى حد ما وحمالات اوجه هل
فعلا قررت انقر البدء بعمليه بريه واسعه
النطاق في الشمال السوري ام لا
المعارضه الامريكيه والروسيه واضحه
وتمنعها من ذلك
اييه نعم ولكن تركيا لا تستطيع ان تنتظر
اكثر لماذا لان العمليات والتفجيرات
المتتاليه في الفتره الاخيره
اثرت على الشعب التركي واردوغان بين الحين
والاخر يقول لابد سوف نرد بقوه على هذه
العمليات التي
تجري تنفيذها في داخل الاراضي التركيه
بدعم من حزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي الوحدات
الشعبيه يعني من كوباني من من ترفعت منبج
المناطق التي تسيطر عليها هذا الحزب في
شمال سوريا
فاذا لم يستطع هذه المره ايضا كالعاده كل
مره الماضيه ان يؤجل هذا همم
همم يعني العمليه العسكريه داخل سوريا
فسوف يخسر الحاضنه الشعبيه خاصه بالنسبه
للحاضنه الشعبيه في تركيا له لانه يتوعد
ولا يوفي والاهم من ذلك اردوغان قال بان
الاتفاقيات 2018 2019 بين الولايات
المتحده والتركيه بانبي السلطه تسلم
لاهلها طيب ولكن الى الان ما زالت هناك
القوات
الارهابيه متواجدده ايضا هناك الدكتور
معنى انا بس بدنا نفهم لنفهم المشاهدين
همم بالنسبه اليك الموقف الامريكي يعطي
ضوءا اخر اخضر لانقر للقيام بهذه العمليه
العسكريه البريه واسعه النطاق ام لا يعني
همم قصد همم تعتبر نفسها حليف اا اساسي
للقوات الامريكيه
سالفه ان انقره ستفكر اكثر من مره قبل
البدء باي عمليه عسكريه بريه
السيده العزيز تركيه عضو في الحلف الاطلسي
والماده الرابعه والخامسه واضحه عندما
سقطت قنابل
ومدافعون ليبولونيا قبل ايام
استنفرت جميع الدول الحفظ الاطلسي هنا لا
تسقط فقط قنابل و اا بدافع وانما تسقط همم
يعني قتله وعمليات عسكريه داخل
الاراضي التركيه وفي مركز
المدن التركيه وعلى راسي اسطنبول وفي
مركزها فاذا فاذا فاذا هذه الاتفاقيه يعني
نعم هناك اتفاقيه بين تركيا والولايات
المتحده الى جانب انها عضو في الحلف ايضا
ويعني هذه هل تسمح للولايات المتحده ان
يعني تدافع عن حزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي
الوحدات الشعبيه والتي في الفتره الاخيره
وضعتها ايضا
بناء عدد الاتفاقيه التي حصلت بين تركيا
والسويد وفنلنديا بانها هي ارهابيه مره
اخرى ان تدافع عن ابيد الشكل وتترك تركيا
طيب
ونرى من اسطنبول الدكتور بكير اتجان مدير
معهد اسطنبول الفكر شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه دكتور بكير
الى شان
انا خفت واشنطن بوست وقف العشرات من
الاعلانات من كبار المؤدينين على تويتر
مضيفه انا اكثر من 33 جهه تسويق كبرى لم
تعلن على تويتر منذ الاسبوعين المضيعين
ووصفت الصحيفه الامريكيه ذلك
بالمؤشر على مدى تقلب المعلمين بشان سيطره
لهم ماسك على الشريك
ورشه التغيير التي عاصفه بتويتر فتحت باب
الموقع عالم اسرائيل عمال المقالون او
مستقلون من جهه ومن الجهه الاخرى يهرب
المعلنون العشرات من كبار المعلمين على
تويتر اوقفوا اعلاناتهم اكثر من 33 جهه
تسويقا كبرى لم تعلن على تويتر في
الاسبوعين الماضيين وفق صحيفه واشنطن
بوسته لتشهد صفحات العصفور الازرق غياب
افضل 14 معلنا على المنصه من ضمنهم شركات
جيب وجننال موتورز التاني اوقفت الاعلانات
المدفوعه على تويتر بشكل مؤقتا وفي خطوه
مماثله اصدرت مجموعه امكم للدعايه
والتسويق في الثانيه عشر من نوفمبر توصيه
لعملائها بوقف انفاقهم مؤقتا على اعلانات
تويتر علما بان امكم تخدموا اكثر من خمسه
الاف عميلا في 70 دوله بينهم ماكدونالدز
وابل ولم يعرف انتبه على اي من عملائها
التوصيات هذه الخطوات والصفات بالمؤشر على
تقلب للمعلمين وشكوك الوكالات والعلامات
التجاريه حول مستقبل الموقع بعد الاستحواذ
الفوداوي للملياردير الون ماسك عليه ورغم
مساعي ماسك الحثيثه لخفض التكاليف وايجاد
اشكال بديله للارادات يعتمد تويتر بشده
على الاعلانات التي شكلت 90% من ايراداته
العام الماضي في مصر صاحب منصه الجديد
يرجع الانخفاض الكبيره بالايرادات الى
ضغوط مجموعات حقوقيه على المعلنين لمقاطعه
الخدمه لحين توضيح كيفيه تحكم تويتر
بالمعلومات المضلله وخطاب الكراهيه
على كل المزيد من المتابعه معي الان من
سان فرانسيسكو مراسل العربيه رافي بوغسلان
في اهلا وسهلا بك هل يتحدث المعلنون رافي
عن سبب تراجعهم عن الاعلان في تويتر منذ
نحو اسبوعين وهل للمساله جوانب سياسيه قبل
ان تكون تجاريه
نعم يا طالب بكل بساطه خائف يكون من اثار
الموقع القائمين على الموقع بالوقت الحالي
يعني يتعاطون بشكل
بطيء جدا مع المحتوى السيء الموجود على
منصه تويتر وبهذا يعني المعلمين هذا قد لا
يتعارض مع اهداف اعلاناتهم هذا قد يكون
واحد من الاسباب السبب الثاني همم استغنوا
على كبار المسؤولين في التسويق والي هم
دائما على تواصل مباشر مع المعلنين
والشركات اما ال- ال- النقطه الثالثه يللي
ايضا ذكرتها صحيفه الدارديا انه قد يكون
لها جوانب واهداف سياسيه كما نعلم انه
يحاولون قد مجموعه من الشركات الامريكيه
وجهاد سياسيه انه يضغطون همم على تويتر من
حيث الاعلانات لتجميع هذه المنصه حتى ايضا
لا تستخدم هذه نص في المستقبل في حملات
جمع الانتخابيه كما نعرف جميعا انه الى
ماسكو يدعم الحزبه
لما تقول يعني بعض الصحف او بعض المواقع
تقول ان قرارات الهن ماسك لا علاقه لها
بالجانب المادي او التجاري وانما بالجانب
السياسي البحث يعني تحويل منصه تويتر همم
تويتر الى واحد ترويج للحزب الجمهوري ومن
هنا يمكن فهم اعاده الى ماسك تفعيل حسابي
الرئيس السابق دون ترامب
صحيح كم مره بكل تاكيد ان هناك الكثير من
علامات الاستفهام وايضا ذكر في البدايه
عندما قام بهذه الصفقه همم ذكر انه السبب
الرئيسي هو ليس المال وانما للخدمه
الانسانيه همم ولكن هناك علامات استفهام
همم نعم هو اعاده حساب ثاني ويدعم الحزب
الجمهوري وايضا الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب وبكل تاكيد انه الحزب الديمقراطي رح
ياخذ هذا الموضوع بعين الاعتبار لانه ما
يريدون ان يستخدم في همم لحملات
الانتخابيه في المستقبل
العربيه رافي شكرا جزيلا لك رافع على هذه
المتابعه
رفضت المحكمه العليا في بريطانيا
على الاستقلال بدون موافقه الحكومه
البريطانيه واخذ القرار ان البرلمان
الاسكتلندي لا يملك الشرعيه الكافيه
لاجراء هذا الاستفتاء
عبرت الوزيره الاولى
الان الى الموجز الرياضي مع الزميل عبد
الله الدرويش اليك يا عبد الله
[موسيقى]
شكرا يا دكتور حياكم الله الى الموجز
الرياضيه حقق المنتخب المغربي تعادل من
دون اهداف امام المنتخب بكرواتيا وصيفي
بطل كاس العالم مباريات المجموعه السادسه
وتلتقي للمغرب مع بلجيكا لاحد المقبل قبل
مواجهه كندا علم ملعب اثمان ويسع منتخب
الاسود لتجاوز دور المجموعات وتكرار انجاز
86 عندما بلغوا دور ال16
[موسيقى]
وحصل نجم ريال مدريد ولاعب منتخب كرواتيا
لوكا مودريتش على جائزه افضل لاعب في
المباراه
كامله لكنه لم يساهم في اي هدف خلال
اللقاء الذي انتهاء بالتعادل السلبي
تستاهله حامل لقب منتخب فرنسا حمله الدفاع
عن لقبه بفوز كبير على المنتخب الاسترالي
باربعه اهداف بهدف واحد واستراليا سجل
الهدف الاول قبل ان يرده منتخب فرنسا
باربعه اهداف وشهد اللقاء معادله الجيرور
رقم الاسطوره شيري اورلي كاكثر اللاعبين
تسجيلا لفرنسا في المباريات الدولي
وعلينا الاتحاد الفرنسي لكره القدم عن
غيابي لوكا هيرنانديز عن بقيه مباريات كاس
العالم بعد اصابته في الركبه خلال مواجهه
استراليا واكد اتحاد القدم الفرنسي بانه
هرنانديز قد اصيب بقطع في الرباط الصليبي
للرتبه ولم يستكمل البطوله وقد يغيب عن
ميونخ الالماني حتى نهايه الموسم
فاضل لنا مباريات المجموعه الثالثه انتهى
لقاء بولندا والمكسيك بالتعادل السلبي دون
اهداف نجم بولندا ليفاندوفسكي اضاعه ركلات
الجزاء عند الدقيقه الثامنه والخمسين في
ما لم ينجح لاعبوا الفريقين في ترجمه
الفرص الاخرى الى اهداف هذه النتيجه وضع
كل منتخب نقطه في رصيده
تلتقي اسبانيا مع كوستاريكا في بدايته
مشوارهم بالمجموعه الخامسه والتي اعتبرت
مجموعه الناريه حيث تضم ايضا المانيا
واليابان ويعملوا المنتخب الاسباني في
التعلق واستعاده ذكريات جنوبيه افريقيا
عام 2010 عندما توجا بلقبه الاول بعد
خروجه من دوري المجموعات في مونديال
البرازيل ومن الدور الثاني في مونديال
روسيا
اسبانيا يعني لقى بها الثانيه في المشاركه
السادسه عشر في البطوله
انخفاض معدل الاعمار
لان الشباب لديهم طاقه كبيره لتقديم
الافضل ونملك لاعبين اصحاب مرونه تكتيكيه
مثل ردي وهو ما يمنحني الحريه في اختيار
التشكيله المنتخب الاسباني جاهزا بدنيا
رغم ان التجمع كان لمده تسعه ايام فقط
النهائيات العالميه للمره السادسه وكان
افضل انجاز لها في مونديال البرازيل عندما
وصلت الى ربع النهائي اليوم مشوارها امام
اسبانيا في المجموعه الخامسه
تحلم كوستاريكا والتي تعني الساحره الغني
بالاسبانيه تحلم بتكرار نجاحها المونديالي
الذي حققته قبل ثمان سنوات في البرازيل
ابطال البلد الواقعي في امريكا الوسطى
وصاحب المرتبه الاولى في مؤشر الكوكب
السعيد عام 2009 تحدى كل التوقعات في
المشاركه الرابعه لهم بوصلهم الى ربع
نهائي المونديال للمره الاولى
لكن ربما الوضع يختلف قليلا في البطوله
السادسه لهم سيواجهون اليابان والماكينات
الالمانيه
في المجموعه الخامسه
[موسيقى]
الكثير قد يقع على اكتاف حارس باريس سان
جيرمان كيلور نافاس ونجم الفريق جويل
كامبل لاعب ليون الفرنسي
فهل بامكانهما لعب دور البطوله وقياده
المنتخب لتحدا عالميا جديد خصوصا بعد
الوداع الحافل في العاصمه سانكوسي حيث هدف
الالاف وهم يرتدون الوان علم البلاد وقميص
المنتخب الحمراء والبيضاء والزرقاء
تفتتح كوستاريكا حملتها في كاس العالم
امام اسبانيا في 23 من هذا الشهر ثم تلعب
امام اليابان في السابع والعشرين وتختتم
دور المجموعات بلقاء المانيا في اليوم
الاول من الشهر المقبل
بين كمبيوتر
90 دقيقه نسعى لالحاق الضرر بالخصم عبر
خطتنا علينا ان نطلب اكثر واكثر من كل
لاعب اللاعب جميعهم سعداء بتواجدهم هنا
لمشاركتهم في هذه المباراه الاولى في كاس
العالم نحن هنا الان ونامل ان نحقق نتائج
جيده في المونديال مستهل لنا ذلك باداء
جيد امام اسبانيا
اليوم بلجيكا مع منتخب بكندا ضمن المجموعه
السادسه ففي ظلي تشكيله من النجوم تضم الى
جانب دي بروين الحارس المتعلق تيبو كورتوا
والمصاب حاليا روميلو لوكاكو تصنف بلجيكا
كوحده من المرشحين البارزين ومع بلوغ
الغالبيه العظمى من نجومها مرحله اعمال
الثلاثينيات يبدو ان كاس العالم المقبل
ستكون اخر محطات هذه الجيل من بينهم كيفن
دي بروين وبعد تاهل الى ربع نهائي كاس
العالم 2014 خسرت بلجيكا امام الارجنتين
لكنها تقدمت خطوه بعدها باربع سنوات
بتهلها الى نصف النهائي وخسارته امام
فرنسا حامله اللقب وكانوا قد وصلوا الى
دوري الثمانيه في نسخه 2014 في البرازيل
دينا شعور بان المباراه الاخيره اعطتنا
فكره عما ينتظرنا في المباريات الدوليه
القادمه في كاس العالم
واحيانا ان يكونوا من الجيد ان نعمل على
بعض الامور التي تنقصنا وينبغي ان نكون
جاهزين لردود الفعل المناسبه على ارض
الملعب طبعا المباراه الاولى مهمه للغايه
من اجل مشوارنا في البطوله
وتبدو مهمه كندا في التفوق على ظهورها
السابق في نهايات كاس العالم لكره القدم
بسيطه اذا انها تحتاجه لتسجيل هدف واحد
عندما تواجه بلجيكا واتاهل كندا للمره
وتاهل كندا للمره الاولى في نحو اربعه
عقود انجاز بحديثاته يعكس ان البلد
المشهور بقوته في منافسات هوكل الجليد لم
يعد غريبه عن عالم كره القدم وبقياده
الفول السودانيفز لاعب بايرن ميونخ كانت
كندا اول دوله في الاتحاد امريكا الشماليه
الوسطى الكاريبي
في النهائيات
امام المنتخب البلجيكي تمثل امتحان مهما
بالنسبه لنا وبلشك المهمه صعبه على اعتبار
ان المنتخب المنافس يملك خبرات كبيره
وسنحاول استغلال الفرصه لكي يقدم افضل
المستويات اعتقد انها ستكون مباراه
الرائعه يشعر بحماس كبير لعودتنا الى كاس
العالم بعد غياب السنوات
[موسيقى]
شكرا
بعد عيب وتذكرتي
اخيرا اظهرت الصور اثار الدمار الذي خلفها
زلزال ضرب جزيره جاوا باندونيسيا وادى
لمقتل العشرات
[موسيقى]
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته